[Music]
hey guys as I was rewarding every
thinking all of game thrones I came up
with this mind-blowing end game theory
that would also be the last promise
shock of game thrones brain start will
kill his father Ned in the past so John
could grow up as danes bastard and
something here is the only sword that
can kill the night King dawn I know that
this might sound ridiculous to most of
you but bear with me at the end of this
video this mind-blowing theory will make
sense and believe it or not John growing
up as Danes bastard that becoming the
sword of the morning heralding the only
store that in the Phaedo night King dawn
was records original plan that's why he
left him at a tower of joy and that's
why Dane could not tell me the truth but
had instead fire him in order to kill
him and pass John as his own which as we
all know he did not succeed let's start
with the help of Holland really feed him
and therefore Rhaegar's and Danes plan
failed and that's why we had brain Stark
who will rewrite history and make sure
John gets the only weapon that's capable
destroying the night king okay so
somewhere near the end of season a
Justin when the most of the living side
will be defeated and killed an easy
night King but John did get an
opportunity to kill the leader of the
white walkers he stabbed a knight king
with his Valyrian steel sword Longclaw
but nothing happened the night king
killed him a few months later at the end
of all of this brain stark realizes for
the help of his visions that the only
thing capable of destroying this night
king is the oldest most magical and most
popular sword in all of Westeros dawn
the ancestral sword of house Dayne only
Don can bring the dawn but it's too late
John had to have done during his
one-on-one fight against the night King
John Harris chance but vase dead with
the wrong weapon and all of skilled
fighters are dead at this point and
brands got no idea where this or demon
is Brenda remembers the last time he saw
Dane Don and John all together which was
at the Tower of joy
Brandon has a vision Amy final triggers
plan was for Dane to pass John as his
own making sure John gonna get killed
and making sure Jon gets done some day
and uses it in a fight against Annette
King but Ned Stark basically messed up
all the plans and all the chances of
Westeros surviving the long night
the dawn is not the only reason Rhaegar
chose deign to act as John's father yes
it will be the weapon that will save all
of Westeros at the end but for John to
grow up and eventually used on against
the night King Gregor made sure that he
would not be killed by Robert after his
birth Targaryen have their unique traits
with silver hair being the most
prominent one and even though Targaryen
genes are recessive to star genes
Rhaegar could not risk it and that's why
it had to be Dane who would not only
give John dawn but also past John as his
own and not someone else for example Ned
it's coming for Danes to look like the
garius with her hair usually being
silver and ice violet had John inherited
his father's looking at these matters
nobody would have ever suspected that
son of dane was not actually attained
but a Targaryen so the sword dawn is not
the only reason Rhaegar chose Dayne to
be the one to raise John and that's why
he's King a best friend Rhaegar won it
they inherit the Tower of joy and that's
why Dane could not let nan to see his
sister Lyanna and that's why he had to
kill him or at least try Rhaegar always
plan for his son to be raised as Danes
bastard at serval making sure no one
would doubt him a Targaryen even if he
would look like one and making sure he
gets done with which he'll someday kill
the night king and end long night
in other words Reagan he was going to
die against Robert that day he no Liana
was going to die in a childbirth and he
knew his son will be killed if Robert or
anyone else ever finds out he's his son
which would also leave Westeros doomed
and everything I talked about for the
last minute is exactly why Rhaegar left
Dane with Lena in the Tower of joy
Prince Rhaegar commanded his guard his
best friend to take care of his son and
to make sure he'd live because he's the
person that is destined to kill the
night king after this vision brain will
realize that it was always meant for his
father Ned to die that day and for John
to grow up as Danes bastard in Harry
dawn and use it in his own chance
against the night king that he wasted
using Longclaw and doomed all of
Westeros brain realizes he's got to
change the past and kill his own father
for any of this to be possible before we
continue with the theory let me just
clarify that this will not be the first
time brain changes passed
he already rewrote it in season six and
in the very same time period let's take
a look on a scene from season 6 episode
3 as Ned runs know the Tavor to finally
in a brain calls out to him that stops
to look around but it's confused because
he cannot find the source of the voice
before brain can discover what's in the
tower for himself the three-eyed Raven
brings both of them out of the past it's
very important to highlight when brain
question whether or not his father heard
him the three-eyed Raven did not deny
the possibility of that being true in
fact he seemed to think that it could be
the case but nevertheless he Pony brain
to leave the vision as soon as possible
whereupon he warned brain not to
interfere with the past maybe he knew
brain had the power to make contact with
other people in this vision and didn't
want brain to accidentally change the
course of history just like on the show
error stark also seemingly hurt his
future son's voice in the books as well
let's take a look on brains last chapter
in a dance dress
Lord Eddard Stark set up on a rock
beside a deep black pool in the godswood
the pale roots of the heart tree
twisting around him like an old man's
north arms the great sword ice lay
across Lord Eddard slab and he was
cleaning the blade with an old cloth
Winnefeld brain whispered his father
looked up who's there he asked if
naturally did hear his future son's
voice then bran could in fact be able to
change the past which would
automatically change the present as well
in my opinion brain has already changed
the past by calling out to his father it
may have not been a significant change
but he could still prove that he is able
to do so let me remind you that brain
coda to his father in episode 3 of
season 6
however season 6 finale proved that bran
has actually rewritten the past as you
can see that Ned now always hears brain
and turns around so there certainly is a
chance that brain can actually change
the past and in some way communicate
with people from different time periods
and if true this would be a major game
changer regarding the outcome of the
Great War perhaps that where Raven was
wrong when he said that the past is
already written
additionally in this scene he seems to
know that brain builds huge power and is
in fact able to rewrite the history
because the brain could not do it then
what would be the point of a warning
pray not to interfere with the past
anyways back to the theory so brain goes
back in time and works in tow day in and
kills Howland and then his fighter net
as well the only survivor of the battle
at the Tower of joy day in passes John
is his own brain Stark rewrote history
how could brain defeat Knight vandeyn
couldn't well first off dane was far
better than ed and he would have killed
him if not for
and who stabbed him from the back they
did not see this coming but brain Ville
as he already watched the entire fight
and no brain is not skilled enough to
kill his fighter net but they miss and
by working into Dane brain gains all the
skills they in his and therefore ezel
defeats and kills Ned as well as Holland
who brain nerves is going to try to stab
him from the back just as brain worked
into horror Ravens entire walls
throughout the previous seasons and
gained all their strength and speed
among all other skills while being in
their skin brain Yuna warg into Dane in
the past again all his skills well-being
in his skin and kill his own father for
Jon to be raised as Dana stifle so he
could become the next sword of the
morning and get the dawn the only weapon
capable of killing the night king and be
able to use it at the right time then
we're back at the present time with the
night King defeated as Jon now used on
his recent fight against the night
England ending the long night
by doing this brand saves Westeros and
Jon brings dawn but it's not only Ned of
House Stark who disappears from big part
of the history bran wipes out most of
his family himself his sister Stenson
Aria and his brother akin all
disappeared from the history and from
the current timeline as all they were
not born by the time fire to the Tower
of joy takes place Robb Stark is the
only one that's not wiped from the
history and the only one of the stars
that will be alive in the current
timeline as well since if this theory is
to capture Ned is long gone and he is
not killed by Lannisters bittersweet
ending is that at the end John kills
night king with dawn and brings the dawn
Brent saves Westeros but the only stark
alive is Robb the only child and the
Catalan got pregnant before Ned went
into Robert's rebellion all that are
Starks are gone this will also be the
last shock of game Jones the prom is the
third one the first five seasons of game
journals were mostly based on published
novels although the beginning late in
season five the series began including
plot points from the future novels told
to the executive producers by author
george RR martin beginning with season
six the show included a large amount of
original content as well as adapting an
outline of future novels provided by
Martin the producer stated there were
three holy moments revealed by Martin
shearing Baratheon's death the meaning
of Horrors name and its relation to his
eventual death and the third to be
revealed at the end of the series in
this theory this third holy moment is
brain killing his father Ned for the
greater good
although don't worry Martin spontaneous
a note of an increase about whether to
share what's for the final two novels
and the producer stated so much of what
we are doing diverge from the books at
this point there are certain key
elements that will be the same
only a few plot points from the series
have been confirmed to be intended for
future novels Warren stated that Tyrion
and Danny will intersect and then when
Taylor stated that Martin told him John
and Danny would meet and Ally against
the other Skywalker's so even if this
does happen on the show it doesn't mean
it will happen exactly the same as in
the books just a Shireen's death will
not happen in the books as echo the same
as it happened on the show anyways I
know we must have been confused at the
beginning of this video when I stated
that bran will kill his father Ned in
the past so John could grow as Dane son
and Sunday and Harry the only store that
can kill the night king dawn and be able
to use it at the right time during his
only chance but now at the end hopefully
it'll make sense and hopefully you like
this brand new mind-blowing endgame
theory of mine and as always I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]